hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar the role of the laboratory in
managing thyroid health i am marie stone
of lab roots and i'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by lab roots
and brought to you by abbott
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits window at the bottom of your
screen to obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
having received training at singapore
general hospital for internal medicine
dr
choon
has garnered tremendous research and
experience related to laboratory
medicine and endocrinology
including that of thyroid health and
disease management in addition to
publishing over 160 professional
articles dr ah has received the
inspiring mentor award and has given
over 340 lectures around the globe
dr all will now begin the presentation
good morning
good afternoon good evening
everyone who's joining us today from
wherever you are
i thank you for
joining us for this uh session on
thyroid testing and the role of
thyrotrophin receptor antibodies
i want to thank abbott for
arranging
this webinar
let me tell you what i will do today um
the
uh with after this short introduction i
will let you in on the lesser known
facts about thyroid function tests which
are
critical for uh practicing
laboratorians and clinicians
then i'll move into
tsh receptor antibodies
the types and measurement
its role in diagnosis as well as its
role in treatment and end with some
concluding remarks
well the repertoire of thyroid tests we
have
includes the thyroid hormones tsh
3t4 and 3t3 which is largely replaced
total hormones
we have the antibodies
right trap
tpo antibodies and thyroglobulin
antibodies and also ability to measure
serum thyroglobulin for
patients with thyroid cancer monitoring
in the assessment we use the thyroid
test for diagnosis monitoring treatment
there's some caveats when we test in
patients and
increasingly
the case is the screen pregnant women
for thyroid dysfunction
a little revision on thyroid physiology
uh
hypothalamic factors
release
trh or tsh
releasing hormone acting on the
pituitary to
stimulate production of tsh and tshx on
the
thyroid to produce t4
and a little bit of d3
right what is often forgotten is that 80
percent
of the t3
comes from the further metabolism of t4
outside of the thyroid and then
thereafter there's uh
target tissues upon which the thyroid
hormones act
and its effects are manifest with
feedback regulation
critical in understanding thyroid
testing
is the
tsh3t4 relationship
since the introduction of third
generation tsh assays
at that time it was shown that
a
twofold change
in three t4 concentrations
would be accompanied by a hundred and
fifty fold change
in
the tsh signal
thus
the signal for tsh is so much greater
than that for free t4
such that for minor degrees of thyroid
dysfunction you are going to see a more
reflection in a change in tsh
we have recently re-evaluated the
tsa-3t4 relationship at this year's aacc
meeting and
using the
the abbott
architect essay right we show that in
this essay today a two-fold change in
free d4 from
14 to 28 picomoles per liter is
accompanied by a 350 fold change
in the tsh signal
because of this
superiority of tsh right most
laboratories will do a tsh first
testing algorithm or a tsh plus 3t4
such that if it is
high
or low
tsh
we go down the appropriate pathways to
either
primary
hypothyroidism
primary hyperthyroidism
and then when both are
normal
with a change in the tsh
there's this entity called subclinical
hypo or hyperthyroidism
and then
when the tsh is high
and the free t4 is also high then
we have to consider
some more unusual causes such as assay
interferences
pituitary secreting tsh tumor
or thyroid hormone resistance
and equally when we have a
low tsh and a low free t4 then a
pituitary tumor or previous bitu surgery
or radiotherapy has to be considered
when we derive reference ranges for
thyroid hormones
we have to remember the possible
interfering factors
that could
affect the values for our reference
population
and
you will see that many of the
interfering factors
include
drugs that the patients may be taking so
a good history
of
drug consumption or treatment is
particularly important
for all the parameters
that we have
and
it is
well known that
it
from top to bottom right we have got
many drugs that can affect
the tsh
as well as
t4
one of them uh that is particularly
interesting is amiodarone
which is a great
anti-as rhythmic drug and the reason is
because amiodarone has
two iodines in its structure
such that
because of its long half-life right the
iodine gets deposited in the body
and the effects of a neodrone in
patients
up to maybe about 10 or 20 percent of
patients may suffer a mulderon related
thyroid dysfunction
and
uh we may be called upon to try and
assist whether it is a type 1 or type 2
thyroid uh dysfunction
right type one is in patients that have
latent or
some
nodular disease
all right
and
the iodine in the miron
adds fuel to the fire and increases
the
symptoms
equally on the other side we have
another type where the iodine suppresses
or even is toxic
to the thyroid tissue
and the
management and outcomes are quite
different
in fact the
type 1
induced thyroid dysfunction
is
you know more difficult to treat
compared to the type 2.
let me come back to
reference ranges in tsh this document
from the nacd guidelines
is often forgotten right it's a good
close to 20 years now
where the
expert committee recommended that we
should
take at least 120 rigorously screen
normal euthyronic volunteers
with no history or family history of
thyroid dysfunction
no visible or powerful gorgeous no
medications
and most importantly
no thyro auto antibodies are measured by
a sensitive immunoassay
right frequently
most
laboratories uh either adopt the
manufacturers
um
cut off values
or verify uh
with a smaller
set
but we in reality right if we use very
strict criteria of no thorough
antibodies then
you're going to find that the reference
ranges are tighter
and this is what we found uh
in
uh
study in in malaysia in a community uh
health fair you find that uh
the range of values
in women was point three to four point
four and in men was point three to four
and if we take the
um
the middle
uh 97 and a half
right after log transmission right this
is what you see and so you have much
tighter values
of upper limit of about three
the lower limit is still about point
four point five
another uh thing to be cognizant of is
that yes as one gets older right the
tsh tends to grow
go even higher and
this is data
from the u.s
national health survey the ann haynes
uh where they showed that yes there is
an effect but it's more so in the very
old
80 plus where the tsh would be uh much
higher that the 75th 97 and the 0.5
centaur is
7.5 in the 80 plus whereas up to 70 it's
still about 4.3
another thing is the ground is shifted
previously we used to think that
subclinical thyroid dysfunction would
always inevitably lead to overt uh
thyroid dysfunction
and
in the last
several years now there's increasing
uh trend towards not treating and
observing uh patients with subclinical
hyper and hypothyroidism and this is
very well summarized in this
review
in lansing endocrinology
two years ago
for instance
in
older patients
also those that have uh
tsh lesson seven all right subclinical
hypothyroidism
right the um inclination is to observe
equally in um
subclinical hyperthyroidism all right if
the patients
uh also uh older or um
at the lower
range of the free t4 and
3t3
that tend to
hold off on
any
immediate treatment
and the reason for this
is that if we look at the natural
history of untreated hyperthyroidism
right there are effects of time
uh
at two years follow-up right 17
of
uh
subclinical
hyperthyroidism the range of 0.1 to 0.4
would normalize
by five years it goes to 32
and at seven years up to a third of them
would normalize
also if we look at
the initial tsh values
in
patients over 60
right at one year follow-up
those with 0.05 to 0.5
three-quarters of them normalized
and of those with the tsh less than 0.05
13
will normalize and of all patients with
low csh are close to 60
normalized
so
again underscoring that
for subclinical hyperthyroidism right uh
there's virtue in
waiting and staying your hand and
observing
[Music]
if we look at patients with subclinical
hypothyroid
you find that
most of those patients
are actually
a little over treated right so you find
the
um
the green
bars are those that remain subclinical
hypothyroid 14
to 26
remain subclinical hypothyroid
but
if you look at the
purple bars
right they become subclinically
hyperthyroid from over treatment ranging
from 13 to 27 percent
and
in the blue
sex sector you'll find that
uh anywhere from one
to
ten percent
uh
hyperthyroid right suggesting that uh a
lot of the hypo hypothyroids
uh iatrogenic in origin and uh should
not be overly
treated
another thing to remember is
testing our patients who are sick
especially when they are hospitalized
because
they are more likely to be sick
euthyroids and where the body responds
to the illness rather than
a true thyroid dysfunction
in fact
the t3
often declines
and
when they recover
it normalizes
the
this is due
to a shift in the metabolism from t3 to
reverse d3
equally there could be a diminishing in
tsh
with a slight elevation
in the free p4 but the total d4 declines
as well
so
best to avoid
treating
or investigating patients
in hospital
but
if so
keep this in mind that
they could be secure thyroid rather than
true thyroid dysfunction
let me shift gears now to thyroid
auto antibodies as you know there are at
least three
important viral antibodies we measure
the tsh receptor antibodies
antibodies directed against the tpo and
antibodies against thyroglobulin
right in autoimmune
thyroid
disease
like hashimoto's paradise right almost
uh over 90 or even 100
right have uh tpo antibodies
equally
with improvements in assays right
patients with graves disease over 80 to
90 percent have got tsh receptor
antibodies
right
so the
tsh receptor antibodies
of a few salts
right
the most common is the inhibition
of tsh binding by the
immunoglobulins so we measure the
inhibition of label tsh
binding to recombinant css receptor by
antibodies present in the serum
when the field first started right there
was interest in trying to measure uh the
stimulating antibodies which is
evidenced by the production of cyclic
amp in thyroid satellites
that have been transfected with the tsh
receptor
but this is a kind of
laborious and
you know only available
in
research laboratories
and then from
the congenital hypothyroid screen he
began to be realized
that
some of the
children
uh
with
what appeared to be
esther's receptor antibodies with
hypothyroid profiles
were actually because this antibodies
instead of being stimulatory are
actually blocking
but for the most part most of the tsh
receptor antibodies are
stimulatory and so the assays that
measure
the inhibition of psh binding is kind of
like a total antibody measure
so the tsa receptor antibodies have got
both stimulating antibodies a small
amount of blocking antibodies
as well as some neutral antibodies
to complicate matter sometimes in the
evolution of disease all right there
could be a change in the proportion of
these antibodies
notwithstanding it the vast majority
are all uh
probably um
stimulatory
that can be measured and good
correlation with the
tbi assays
so the
utility of the tsh receptor antibodies
because
they modulate the thyroid follicular
cell function
they may be involved in the pathogenesis
of graves
ophthalmopathy and possibly also in
osteoporosis
because
this tsh receptor antibodies
iggs they can cross the placenta during
pregnancy
and
be involved in
fetal thyroid dysfunction
right
the greater value would be as a measure
of
autoimmune hyperthyroidism right where
the diagnosis of graves disease is
difficult or in grace of thermopathy
especially in
um
unilateral um
you know eye swelling
and the main
utility today is uh
in uh also
the prediction of uh neonatal
pyrotoxicosis
as well as
in american
induced hyperthyroidism
so the
bioassays
because
it's less available more expensive and
more tedious all right have largely been
replaced uh by the
tbv iii assays which are automated
and uh
using
chemiluminescence
and
other
non-isotopic assays
so the bioacids have given away to the
competitive immunoassays
and
there's also now
a
tsi the stimulatory immune goblins which
is automated as well
from
imelite
so the indications for tsh receptor
antibodies are mainly in diagnosis right
for grace hypothyroidism
uh patients with uh ophthalmopathy right
especially
unilateral
and sometimes uh in this rare condition
where they have got skin involvement and
you're not one is not sure uh what it is
all right so uh
presence of tsh receptor antibodies
would be helpful
and in
the fetus and neonatal period all right
especially in
mothers with graves disease right the
likelihood of
neonatal paratoxicosis
should be considered when the tsu
receptor antibodies are positive in
mummy
a big change today is
the
chance of remission of hyperthyroidism
right a high baseline trab on diagnosis
would
mean that
remission is unlikely
and
the treatment may need to be longer all
right usual uh usually
hyperthyroid patients are treated with
antithyroid drugs for 18 months and then
after that we stop
and observe to see whether they
relapse or not on average about 50
percent of patients relax
and so uh increasingly uh the the use of
the tsh receptor antibodies at diagnosis
a year
or at 18 months
to monitor whether or not to continue
anti-thyroid drugs
so on
for diagnosis today if
a patient has got a clear-cut uh signs
of hyperthyroidism uh
we don't need the tsh receptor
antibodies however
if
the
features are less
obvious
tsh receptor antibodies would help
the sites also providing a baseline
indicator for prognosis
the assays have greatly improved
such that the sensitivity
of
the dsh receptor antibody for graves
disease with the new third generation
assays are better than 95 percent
and
the specificity has also improved
right uh
i just want to show you uh this that
came out a few years ago
where the
immunite assay for the
stimulation
antibodies was
introduced and this is uh
looking at the correlation with the
previous radial receptor assays and you
find that
there is clearly uh you know a good
distinction between graves disease and
other thyroid um
disorders like autoimmune thyroid
disease
non-toxic goiter
and
normals as well as multinodular
goiters
so
quite a good separation
and then another group also
confirmed
that the
essay
with this
immunity essay was also quite
good all right
and you can see this roc curve to
diagnose graves disease
right
at
0.57 units of trab had a sensitivity of
98 percent and a specificity close to
100 percent
so the performance of tsh receptor
antibody assays continue
to
demonstrate good performance all right
this is uh
uh a recent paper from last year all
right looking at two uh third generation
uh essays the crypto and the roche
assays all right very good uh
correlation
uh good position less than 10 percent
and
with
cutoffs
or you know
even in healthy volunteers right 90
percent
of them had a trab
that was below the limit of detection or
the lod
and you can see that the precision
is quite good
in both these
essays
and uh
more studies right this is a another
recent paper this year comparing uh the
crypto with the imeolite and the madume
and
this is blend almond plots to show that
the
results
were very close
so
again another
paper this year
that the
comparing the imelite and the roche
the roc for diagnosis of graves disease
0.4
on the imilite
all right which is a simulatory assay
and uh 2.7 on the roche right so
the positive rate was family fairly
similar uh using
uh cutoffs supplied by the manufacturer
or derived from the roc analysis
okay
all right we done with graves a
diagnosis of graves hyperthyroidism
right let's move to
uh orbital
graves
right now this is grace uh obitocy or
grace of thermopathy right
you know very
obvious
sort of uh stairy look right and
this is after uh the patient has had
some
surgery
now
um when
patients are treated right
they improve
and uh
you know
if they have
either no
uh optometry or mild uh symptoms right
after
they respond right more of them
have
improvement in the aftermarketing
another recent
paper
uh
looking at serial tsh receptor in
antibodies
right
it can
help to inform
the timing of intervention all right in
the thyroid eye disease if the
trab levels are increasing then
the
treating doctors may be
persuaded to
do some intervention
[Music]
the studies
on its
use as a predictor of eye disease
is increasing showing good correlation
between the initial treb levels and
clinical activity scores
one of the things that's known uh is
that smokers with
orbital graves
have
worse outcomes
and
the
this is
evidenced by
how the decline in the tsh receptor
antibodies was delayed
by over a year
in those who continue to smoke
and
even also
when patients are treated
right generally the
tsh receptor antibodies decline so it
can also be used
in its
monitoring and to aid
decision making
this is a recent
paper
on
the use of the stimulating antibodies
the tsi on the immune line however
you know the
roc curve was only 0.6
right
little
underwhelming
but part of the reason is because
we now know that besides the tsh
receptor
in the immunopathogenesis of atomic
grace there's also an igf-1
receptor that's involved and the
pathogenesis of authentic
graves disease is a bit more complicated
than uh what we used to believe that
all of it was mediated by the tsh
receptor antibody
however uh an interesting then a
new treatment has come out of
this tra bees right there's
a blocker for trabes right an antibody
blocker right so this is a patient right
on the upper panel and then after
treatment you can see there is
improvement right this is without
surgery and what they did was to give
this drug uh
k
170 right this is still uh just
published online in thyroid all right so
you see on this side here the patient's
serum tsab declining all right and
the
they were given
intramuscular
doses of
k 170
over several weeks intervals
so this is something that we
need to keep an eye on
okay to assist in diagnosis another one
is this is a very unusual uh
skin change in patients with grace right
especially in the early stages it we
would not know what what it is and if
they have got
tsh receptor antibodies present then
we can
be more confident that this is grave
democracy rather than
something else
so we have covered
hyperthyroidism as well as
orbital and skin changes
of grace
helping in the diagnosis right now i
want to talk a little bit about the
fetal and neonatal paratoxicosis
right in pregnancy
women with graves disease
with the maternal travs
they can cross the placenta and and
cause uh fetal as well as neonatal
paratoxicosis and this this diagnosis is
not so easily made right because uh you
know all all babies have a rapid heart
rate they uh bit uh
stress they cry so um it is often missed
and only diagnosed late
but if
mummies have a high
trad then
the doctor should
consider this and
maybe evaluate the trab
in
and turret function
in the child
but it's a it's only a rare occurrence
right we're not sure why this happens
like some genetics some environmental
factors
uh
the
level at which
this
occurs
maybe around
five units on the brahms essay
the
correlation between the
binding assay in the tsa spinning
inhibitory as the other of the rush as
well as the stimulating antibodies of
the siemens um
seem to be about equal
in this regard
also
there's trab that i mentioned earlier
that
was found in patients with congenital
hypothyroidism
all right and
when they looked further into this right
the the few cases
showed that the the trnbs there were not
stimulatory
right
but were blocking to cause
hypothyroidism
so um
whether or not
this may be useful uh for
uh
diagnosis in this
uh
congenital hypothyroid uh screening uh
scenario uh will await for the
larger studies
right
so uh the next area i want to talk about
is um
in the treatment which is the best use
of
the tsh receptor antibodies which is
what is the likelihood of remission and
how does it guide the treatment
in treatment of graves disease we can
use antithyroid drugs we can use
radioactive iodine or we can go for
surgery
but the
drugs remain
the preferred modality
right
because
it's easy to administer all right the
uh
core mobilities
uh are less
plus
there's also some information about the
kinetics of
tsh receptor antibodies
that
influence this decision
you see that
over the years right
the
uh use of
uh drugs is increasing in the u.s right
this is a study that was reported
in thyroid a few years ago right the the
diamonds right the squares is radiided
radio iodine is coming down
and surgery has kind of remained
steady
right if we look at the treb kinetics of
treatment right medications bring down
uh the proportion of treb levels
quite well
followed by surgery
and then in radioidin takes a longer
time and in fact in the first several
months there is a paradoxical rise in
the trab
following
radio
iodine therapy
right so this is the
another study showing uh the rapid
decline
with surgery right
versus the
the increase
in
trab with radio iodine and the slower
decline in with radioitem
and
the probability of the system
the high
tpii is much lower with surgery versus
radioid
so
the trab has influenced uh the choice of
treatment modality
right
many
have been interested in this question of
can we not use the trab to predict who
is going to relapse in graves disease
and this is a
meta-analysis in
2017.
uh
it shows that the
trabs represent a significant marker for
relative risk of relapse
at about 0.3
and then if we look at uh five different
tsh receptor antibodies
right all s's are capable of predicting
uh
you know the relapse of graves disease
right and there's also been a trend to
try and improve
the predictive score by
coming out with something called the
great score
right so
uh
h all right uh less than 40 you give one
point
uh you know free t4
more than 40 another point
uh
you know tbii more than 22 points
and uh quite the size another two points
so the maximum score is six
and if you have a class three grade
score
the risk of recurrence is close to 70
percent
so here is the um
in figures the
recurrence rate
right over time
by the different classes of grade score
uh so this has also been validated in a
larger data set of uh 740 patients
again the same this is the kepler meyer
curve of relapses all right so
the
uh
the lower your your uh
rate score class right the probability
of remission is much higher
then we have outcomes of uh
graves disease with antithyroid drugs
and the time course of the
tsu receptor antibodies
right
if the initial levels
the likelihood of becoming a
new thyroid at 51 months was
you know
much
lower those that have higher median trav
levels took longer time for emission
and those who could not attain targets
with very high initial levels more
likely for flare-ups
and
serial
trap levels are much
more informative
and so again the higher the trap level
at diagnosis the less likely to achieve
remission
and
another
group
in denmark right two centers over 200
patients
again showing that
trapped negative with normal tsh for two
months
uh
with
five milligrams of methimazole right
would be uh the control group so the
predictors for lack of remission would
be
trap levels
more than five
and this is an odds ratio of 3.4
so the utility of trab for
grace disease would be
well
at presentation right the risk of
relapse is 50 to uh two-thirds right
for all patients
but if the trap is more than 12 right
the
relapse rate is uh 60
at two years and 84 at four years
so
um one could say that perhaps uh you
might want to discuss radioiodine
therapy right
right in some time
now if the trab is uh
more than 7.5 after
12 months
or uh
after 18 months
and at when the
anti-thyroid drugs have stopped and the
trab is still more than 3.8
then
you know they have a high likelihood of
relapse
so either we continue giving
anti-thyroid drugs
or uh to consider
other treatment modalities
so this is how one group in the uk is
using
this information of trav
given the fact that we talked about uh
stimulating blocking as well as total
travs
should we
subtite
for diagnosis the difference is less
important
and
you know both the tsi and tbi will
decrease with the
initiation of anti-thyroid drugs right
of course respondents more than the
non-responders
tfi measured by bio essay is technically
challenging and the automated platforms
like
immolite will be preferred
however
the
there's no
great difference between the tsi and
the
tbri currently
but the subtyping may have value in
complicated situations such as
prediction of neonatal thyroid
dysfunction
or an unusual
grave disease with severe
eye disease
or when patients
may not be responding and one wonders
whether
there is a change in
the type of
travs right whether it's a tsh binding
inhibition versus stimulation
so in summary
essays now can assess
tsh binding inhibition
as well as
thyrox stimulating ibg the newer third
generation assays now have superior
performance
and we have got specific
tsi essays but
you know it
it's used in
reserve for the more difficult cases
some variation exists between the essays
and more standardization and
harmonization would be helpful
trap can be used to predict remission
and relapse
trap levels persist longer after
radioidin than after surgery
it can also be used to predict the risk
of eye disease
and
high maternal trab increases the risk of
neonatal paratoxicosis
and in some cases the blocking
antibodies may also
be
involved in
congenital hypothyroidism
and
you know a few years ago
i wrote an editorial saying is it ready
for prime time
i think uh the answer is uh definite yes
okay thank you very much uh ah
final slide in this season of saskoff 2
one wonders if
diabetes is a risk factor
what about
thyroid disease
so far
other than a few case reports of
subacute thyroiditis occurring
the
presence or absence of thyroid
dysfunction and its treatment
has not been found to influence
fast of two
prognosis
or cause of disease so we would need to
watch this space further
remember that thank you very much
thank you dr ah for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
dr maria bhandari phd pmp manager
scientific affairs at abbott will
address questions due to time zone
differences in singapore
we will ensure that we provide you an
answer to all the questions posed
and we will forward unanswered questions
to professor ah for his insights and
follow-up with response via email
let's get started
our first question is
what is the difference between tsab and
tsi
hi um thank you so much uh and maria um
hopefully you can hear me um yeah okay
yes uh good okay um thank you so much
yeah uh uh
you know for the question and everyone
attending the this webinar um
just very quickly and something uh
before we start with the question just
want to make sure that everyone um it's
aware that this webinar uh as we have in
the screen it's entirely as a scientific
educational session to inform
laboratories as well as healthcare
professionals
as you saw with all the latest research
and published data
so the views and
uses demonstrated in this presentation
may not necessarily reflect the current
regulatory uh proofed intended uses or
claim um to just make sure that you know
you check with your
um
you know with your respective areas and
as you know this was you know supported
by abbott um now in reverse of the
question so um ts tsa bees or tsi or t
sub um it's they're essentially the same
thing um
one is
called the thyroid stimulating antibody
that would be the ts
ab
while the other one is called the
thyroid stimulant and immunoglobulin and
that's the psi
however um
the preferred nomenclature is really to
use now the tsh receptor antibodies or
what we call trab
um and like dr all mentioned and which
is good to remember a most of these
traps are stimulating
um
although occasionally there's some
blocking traps as he mentioned as well
and in those cases uh rather than
stimulating they can cause um
instead of causing hypothyroidism they
will cut you know instead of
hyperthyroidism depending on
whether they're stimulating or blocking
all right
next question
what does a high trap baseline and
patients indicate and how does this
relate to their remission and treatment
not sure so um
i think this was kind of towards the end
of the presentation and remember dr all
went through all the different
uses for tram uh whether it's diagnosis
and treatment and actually he made an
important point about this to say that
uh he thinks that uh trab it's one of
the most important uses is during this
uh treatment so
um a high baseline of trab uh it's
confirming that this patient first of
all has a grave hyperthyroidism
and it indicates also that this patient
is very likely to relapse at the end of
the 18 months of medical treatment uh
with the anti-target drugs
um
so this patient it would be really
important to have them uh have the trap
measured uh throughout and actually
before deciding if they're going to
discontinue their medication or not
um
if traps are not normal then most
endocrinologists would most likely
continue the anti-fire drugs further
uh for let's say another three to nine
months
and then they would repeat trafagen
however the trap could also um help
indicate if it's low
uh then it could also indicate that this
likelihood of relapse
would also be low so there's a good
correlation um
when it's done at the diagnosis time
okay thank you next question
what leads to variation or variations in
t3 and tsh when patients are unwell and
what implications does this have for
their diagnosis
sure um
yeah so
one of the things uh to remember um
again this was very early on that dr al
mentioned that
most of the t3 it's not synthetized in
the thyroid
but it actually comes from the further
metabolism
from t3 to t4 and this mainly occurs in
the liver
um
now when patients are ill from
any reason
um the body tries to
conserve the t3
and it shifts the metabolism
to an inactive product which is called
reverse t3 and thus this results in low
t3
tsh on the other hand
uh it's low normal to slightly elevated
and
t4 which normally is free t4
it's often elevated
and so this phenomenon of low t3 with
normal tsas is what we call
euthyrone
hyperthyroid anemia
or in other words it's non-steroidal
illness which is also known by the
letters and ti
and so
the implications for fire tests in this
case is that they really shouldn't be
ordered
unless it's absolutely essential
and just repeat them once the patient
conditions more normal because
it may be related to some other illness
and not really due to a fire condition
and most endocrinologists um know this
um but you know it's something that the
generalist needs to be also cognizant
for
all right well it looks like we have
time for one more question
thank you for presenting the published
data can you elaborate on the scientific
data and literature related to abbott's
trab
i'm sure so
um abbott trap essay is commercially
available now in some markets
uh however make sure to check with your
uh local representative for the
availability as you know it's still
being rolled out and approved in
different areas
um the assay is a chemical monetary
microparticle immunoassay
it is used for the quantitative
determination of
the fire stimulated and hormone receptor
antibodies so trad uh inherent here in
human serum and it will be used also as
an aid and the differential diagnosis of
great disease
uh just like a lot of the assays that
doctor ah talked about um it is a third
generation essay
um
and if it is an automated delay one step
um and so without the need of any
pre-treatment uh the samples can just be
directly incubated and then the trap
present in the sample will compete with
the psa receptor antibodies so just like
the other competitive anaphase
um the abbot assay is
standardized also against the
who's second standard
and in comparison to the other assays it
also has a very good precision
um it has a reportable interval that go
from 0.7 to 500
units per liter uh with also you know
llb 80q other compare comparables as
well um the diagnostic cauda have been
established to be about 3.1
um but the important thing is that just
like some of the
data discussed here this cut off to be
evaluated also for
uh with specimens from individuals with
medical conditions that are unrelated to
grave disease and the results continue
to show gross specificity with that
caught up for the abadazi
and
lastly uh it has a good correlation
and
low bias
against the roche method
and even though they have different
diagnosis caught up
we have that same concordance as shown
with some of the other publications um
and there's a you know greater than 98
percent of positive and negative
agreement within the assays
so that's kind of
i think we're top of the hour yeah
well thank you um thank you again dr ah
for your time today and your important
research and thank you dr bhandari for
answering today's questions
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor abbott for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye